Keeping yourself alive is hard work.
There are bacteria covered children ready
to give you numerous diseases.
There’s delicious junk food that will swell
your heart up and make it stop working.
And there are evil monsters hiding under your
bed, waiting to eat your face, sorry kids
but it’s true.
Most of the time though, we rely on our doctors
to make sure we don’t accidentally trip
and fall face first into an early grave.
They help us to make the decisions about how
best to keep all the nasty stuff at bay, not
that we always take their advice that is;
because you know, there’s stuff like doughnuts
and cheesecake in the world.
But are there situations where a doctor can
say “actually, you know what, I’m afraid
your time is up”?
When times are tough or everything has just
gone wrong, how much say does a doctor have
in whether you should continue to live or
not.
Can a doctor legally kill their patients?
In most parts of the modern world, if you
rushed in to an emergency room with blood
spraying all over the place or a limb dangling
off, you’d expect the nearest doctor to
tell Mrs Johnson her bowel movement diary
will have to wait ‘til next Monday and run
over to help you.
But throughout history, especially while at
war, doctors couldn’t possibly attend all
the patients they had so they would have to
choose who to help.
For a long time, this would have been done
at random, doctors picking the people nearest
to them or simply the ones who smelt the most
pleasant.
But as medicine became increasingly scientific
and statistical, doctors realized that who
they helped, and in what order, could have
a big impact on the long term survival rates
of troops.
During the Napoleonic wars and World War I,
French doctors began using a system called
triage, where they would arrange the injured
into three sections; those likely to live
even WITHOUT treatment, those likely to die
even WITH treatment, and those for whom immediate
care might make a big difference in their
chances.
So, if you’d been shot in the arm, you’d
have to sit and wait.
If you’d been shot in the chest, please
just die quietly in the corner but you with
the bleeding kidney, get over here so we can
sew you up and shut up all your noisy complaining.
This basic model is still what a paramedic
might do today if they were dealing with 50
people on their own.
But there is a surprising lack of consensus
on what to do in a major emergency and often,
even hospitals do not have a concrete policy
for triage.
In the aftermath of Hurricane Katrina, many
hospitals were cut off, without power and
had to make very difficult choices as the
flood water and temperature rose and their
supplies dwindled.
In Memorial Medical Center, New Orleans, a
doctors and two nurses made the difficult
choice to give lethal drug doses to some patients
who were in a great deal of pain and had virtually
no chance of survival.
The case against them for second degree murder
was eventually thrown out by the Louisiana
courts.
So to answer the question, yes in this instance
a doctor was able to legally kill patients.
But its wider impact was a realization that
doctors needed more of a framework to work
with in these horrible situations.
Dr Daugherty Biddison, decided that these
life and death questions should have the input
of the general public and led a series of
forums to see what everyday people thought.
There was general agreement that you should
prioritize the people with the best chance
of living longer but once that was set; how
do you chose within those groups of equal
chance survivors?
Do you pick parents over single people?
What happens to illegal immigrants?
Can you discriminate by age?
And if they are a Belieber, does that put
them at the bottom of every list?
These emergency extremes are fortunately quite
rare and hospitals have often dealt incredibly
well with a sudden influx of patients.
The general public have reacted amazingly
well too; in the aftermath of the Boston marathon
bombings, some competitors who had just run
A MARATHON, kept running to the hospital in
order to give blood.
Bet you feel pretty lazy now, huh?
But these life and death choices come up every
day in hospitals since we now have an amazing
ability to keep people alive when their body
is really letting the side down.
Whatever organ malfunctions, there are machines
to do its work; from kidney dialysis to artificial
hearts and iron lungs.
Even when someone is completely brain dead,
meaning they have no electrical activity in
their brain, we can keep the body going for
about a week.
In 2005, the UK introduced the Mental Capacity
Act, which laid out guidelines for who gets
to make decisions about a patient’s future.
It states that you have the capacity to make
your own medical choices, even if they mean
certain death.
It backs this up by saying that you can’t
be deemed incapable of making decisions just
because you make an unwise choice.
It’s like how your friends still try to
listen to you even though you once said The
Wolverine was the best film ever made.
But if you’re incapable then the choice
reverts to the doctor unless you have already
selected a person to speak for you such as
a parent, a friend or if you have no friends
maybe nominate a fortune cookie you found
on the shelf.
So, you are allowed to refuse care, even if
it’s necessary to keep you alive, but what
about the opposite?
What about when you’re in a hurry to check
out and you want the doctor to be a little
generous on the old morphine?
Euthanasia was looked down on for hundreds
of years, especially among the Judeo-Christian
religions who claimed it went against the
sanctity of human life, in the same way people
who commit suicide were not allowed to be
buried in official cemeteries.
But in 1870, a British school teacher called
Samuel Williams gave a speech in Birmingham
about giving chloroform to terminally ill
patients.
The transcript was published widely and it
sparked an important debate.
In the US, the first attempt to legalize euthanasia
came in 1906 in Ohio, when a wealthy woman
called Anna Hall started a campaign after
watching her mother fight a long and hopeless
battle with liver cancer.
Of course, this isn’t just a decision for
doctors; it’s something the military have
faced for a long time.
A Coup de Grace (“Coo de Gra”) or mercy
killing has happened for centuries when soldiers
take pity on an enemy who is in great pain.
SAS soldier, Sergeant Colin Maclachlan is
currently under investigation for a claim
that he did this in Iraq.
Mercy killings violate the Geneva Convention,
which are the rules of combat.
As for the medical side of things, right now,
euthanasia is legal in The Netherlands, Belgium,
Colombia and Luxembourg.
There is also the case of assisted suicide,
where the patient themselves are the one to
administer the treatment, usually some kind
of drug.
This is legal in four countries and some US
states.
But your best bet to avoid all of this scary
life and death stuff is to just live a good
healthy life and the next time your doctor
advises you to stop drinking so much and do
more exercise you should probably listen.
Because remember, if he’s smart enough he
can probably kill you and get away with it.
Thanks for the view, subscribe for more Thoughty2.